ça n'est pas nouveau la grossophobie est
un mal qui est partout insulté à cause
de leur physique de nombreuses personnes
rondes sont victimes chaque jour de
moqueries ou d'agressions verbales dans
la rue ou sur les réseaux sociaux
absolument insupportable si plusieurs
stars comme lou anne laurence boccolini
ou amel bent s'était fait l'écho de
violentes insultes dont elles sont
victimes au sujet de leur apparence les
attaques envers les personnes en
surpoids sont la cible de toutes les
reproches selon les études en france un
français sur deux est considéré en
surpoids malgré tout dans les médias le
culte du corps parfait et partout
magazine réseaux sociaux émission de
télé tout est fait pour mettre en avant
des tailles mannequins irréel et pousser
les femmes et les hommes à se calquer
sur un modèle unique aux états unis des
émissions comme the biggest loser dont
l'objectif est de perdre le plus de
poids possible pour gagner le jeu font
fureur depuis de nombreuses années en
france les émissions de société ou les
reportages autour du régime de la perte
de poids ou du corps parfait envahissent
nos écrans et contribuer à cette idée qu
être rond c'est négatif récemment c'est
l'artiste marois l'aude qui s'est lancé
dans une campagne contre le body shining
avec son titre allez les gros
et
elle chante sa fierté de ne pas être
comme tout le monde mais malgré cette
autodérision les remarques blessantes et
les attaques gros sofop pleuvent sur
internet à son encontre
ce soir elle était avec nous en direct
pour réagir à ces attaques merci à table
et c'est au moment maroillais les
critiques qu'a eu ce qui a pu avoir ou
pas ça m'a blessé si tu veux quand
j'étais plus jeune
ça va paraître de pré adolescence donc
13 14 ans parce que c'est vrai que
j'avais pas encore la maturité de passer
outre ses critiques là mais c'est vrai
que maintenant ça va toujours me vexer
mais sans les cinq premières minutes
quoi après c'est pas ça tu t'en fous
aussi passé au tour voilà est qui et qui
est déjà été victime de deux goudjil et
non mais je voulais dire que la
grossophobie est considérée comme une
discrimination et elle peut porter
plainte ce sont les articles 225 du code
pénal on peut aller à la gendarmerie à
la police porté plainte et pour tout ce
qui est discrimination à l'embauché liés
à la crosse au à la grosseur y en a
plein de gens surpoids qui sont
discriminés on peut attaquer aux
prud'hommes et c'est pas pris au sérieux
non plus comme une vraie discrimination
quand on va parler de je sais pas de
racisme d'antisémitisme ou même
d'homophobie c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment pris au sérieux
tandis que la grossophobie on pense que
c'est un complexe va on prend pas
vraiment le commissaire la raison vient
de me traiter de gros non non non non
non non ils sont réceptifs maintenant
ils ont été sensibilisés juste en a pas
je vous le dis je suis très drôle ce
serait très long que toi tu ailles au
commissarait tuyaux vient de me traiter
de gros t'es vraiment rien à voir pour
vous la wii moi je me suis je me suis
mangé tous à tester des commentaires
négatifs sont les gens que j'étais
enceinte ça soit tu es enceinte dit la
vérité sur toutes mes photos de cet été
on s'en était parlé et c'est vrai que
c'est dommage parce que la presse
haussier se sert de ses commentaires
pour aussi au final nous attaquer nous
mêmes qui relève tout ça ça fait un
effet boule de neige on se fait aussi
attaqué quand vous dites la presse et
surtout les plus techniques
oui pas de la presse normale après si je
peux me permettre
on est d'accord que quand on dit allez
les gros on n'incite pas non plus les
gens à devenir non justement voit ainsi
je vous entends parler parce que c'est
important d artane aux personnes n'ont
pas compris le message de notre pied
voilà c'est ont pensé que c'était enfin
je suis pas certaine qu'ils y aient
pensé réellement mais je pense que
c'était encore une fois pour titiller
sur mes pensées que c'était de
l'incitation orques pas du tout comme je
le dis dans quelques interviews que j'ai
fait aussi a pas très longtemps c'est
pas une incitation vraiment vraiment
loin de là nous on a voulu parler des
gros entre guillemets parce que ça nous
convient le mieux mais on parle de
toutes les erreurs de discrimination
exactement comme tu en parles est alerte
et décomplexé parce que j'étais un peu
trop maigre tu vas on parle vraiment de
on parle vraiment tout ça et ce n'est
pas une incitation et si demain
quelqu'un est gros et qu'il a envie de
maigrir et que c'est mieux pour sa santé
ou même pour son quotidien parce que ça
devient compliqué peut-être dans son se
sont quotidiens et bien au contraire on
motive ces personnes là aussi à maigrir
ça se trouve dans quelques mois notion
on aura envie de perdre du poids parce
que c'est mieux pour nous mais en tout
cas on veut juste l'acceptation de soi
même si tu es bien dans ta peau gros bas
continue en place et tout sera pas
comment lui cinq fruits et légumes porte